right hello and welcome to today's
Android developers office hours my name
is Nick butcher and I'm joined here in
London by Matt I had Chris Bank regular
is a rich Ivan and Stefan at droidcon
Berlin today so unless the the Wi-Fi
conference gods smiling on their life
don't think they're going to be joining
us so as usual this is your chance to
come and ask us the Android developer
relations team any questions about
developing android apps it's not an
opportunity to ask us about and release
features and products and stuff like
that and roadmap thing needs because
we're not going to be able to share that
part of information unfortunately so
without further ado it seems like we
have a couple of people joining us live
we have Yossi over hello Yahtzee hi guys
and see charm and I can see and who's
that I've just joined as well talk
everyone is joining hi everyone and what
what everyone joins should we start off
by taking a quick look at some of the
questions have been pre submitted into
the moderator yeah that's what let's go
for it so Hugo vissa from netherlands as
a stir is there a supportive way to
change the locale the little cap within
your app is fine why you on
stackoverflow there's a couple of people
of persons that had to do with River
hack by changing the configuration um
and honestly I don't know the answer to
it and I guess it's a hack and it
shouldn't really be done um you've got
actually self one do this okay giving my
follow-up why would you do that sure
that's only user one set and it's that
latest system setting they said it once
it's that language and what is the need
for your apt to change their locale so
it sounds like you can do it but it's a
hack a knob it may not have work in the
future so I guess you answered no you
don't think there is a supported we're
doing it not supported not like in be
cool why not to just the user to choose
the language he wants to see the menus
when the application yeah what you
probably do is probably and deep link
them to the setting in
the screen in settings where they can
change it so rather than automatically
changing you might be able to link them
fruit but I don't know about what's Mata
ki jai together yeah he said whether you
want to be our dinner yeah it sounds
like it's a question of if you've got a
user and you haven't localize your app
Cheers you'll see man thanks see it any
one of the Hangout got a question yeah I
got one or two maybe oh yeah no no first
one not really related to Android but
I'm trying to see if there is a google
groups API do you know anything about it
oh no sorry you can't not my department
I for you to access Google Groups fear
nntp it's like a standard whose group
okay I'll check it out and yeah cuz
that's how it's born wasn't it was like
a web interface to newsgroups and then
it just quite grew into his own not
product so I'm sure they've still got
some bonding somewhere okay often just
some switching thanks all right Stevens
asked the question slide like you can
even eat and ask yourself or you
something without video no no Mike okay
I have a question also can you hear me I
ok you guys read movie magazines yes we
can he hello everyone oh I also added
the question the moderator area oh it's
about the action view intent and the
possibility to add multiple Yuri's for
four images in order for the gallery to
to act as in a slideshow mode
this possible some way no ah ok so I
need to implement something but by
myself in order to provide such a such
an action ok thanks there are a number
of libraries um so open source libraries
in use for this kind of thing and make
it really easy and have a Google ok ok
sugar got two seasons yeah so inside by
Stephen asks is it good practice to open
a connection to the database and then
hold on to it for the lifetime of the
application um the children the trouble
you have it out if you'll never be able
to you will never know when to close the
database because there's not a sort of
on destroy a precaution so you're going
to keep holding on see a flick at the
database connection and it's never going
to be close to behold resources and your
database if you try and open that data
if you're out gets killed the database
won't be closed so that s time you try
to open it you're going to exception
same database isn't closed some time and
so what it is it's a nice easy option to
get around sort of handle of databases I
wouldn't recommend it personally what
would you recommend I don't know the
more the more I'm at sort of five
database them the more content providers
just seeing the best way I think that
there are a lot of boilerplate we have
to write there's a ton of good libraries
will help you write all that for you
like storm and other search of things no
I think content writers probably the way
to go here and have that handle your
database connection yeah I agree yeah
you get a lot of stuff for free you can
use loaders and whatnot yep and you need
to be using this architecture anymore oh
ok cool that was my impression cool good
glad we can confirm that any other live
questions before we jump back into the
moderator there's one guy who's
advertised hip but its hand up I keep
wanting you are asked a question that's
just what's the best way to access
fragments by tag
oh why tank ? guessing falling
tag its method you asking that the
best way to keep hold of them like you
know to get the hold of them than the
air taxes tag is a very good way yeah
great makes a great video watching us
read a sidebar conversation going on for
a few pages oh so if you're using
fragments within a view pager why would
you need to get them by attack though
because you just automatic nap them
looks it's a few isn't it view pager any
deals with views and it's you got
fragment pager adapter which sort of
handles or the fragment decided and so
yeah the way you've put in is a good way
sort of creating a custom tag based on
the position is the way I've done in the
past so much like you've done oh my
opinion incision yeah or you just cry um
custom sort of object lots of strings
that will go to each fragment is this
using a hidden feature is it not sort of
yes implementation-specific is then yeah
anyway that's the way of doing the past
any works so i can't really think about
why doing it sir go for it i'm going to
go question another what tablets in
stomach yeah okay so it's a go back and
simulator ah when you're going to do
this not gonna laugh so multiple images
so we just talked to that one yep okay
so Kenny in Los Angeles says Asherah
section if room doesn't work as I would
expect even when there's plenty of room
these actions on
and it looks through to a stack overflow
Fred we had a chance over girl yeah i
mean the psycho fly fried answer
everyone you've got an answer under
water so it's a pretty definitive answer
basically action bar sort of the number
of items you can have it as action items
is fixed based on the resource so it
based on sort of size of screen what's
of orientation if device in any changes
based on that so sort of for instance on
a 10 inch tablet and like landscape
because five items you can have tea and
yelp too so if you're using if room on
your items it will sort of wrap after
five items but you can't you can force
your items display using always and so
there is that and it is it's kind of me
done that to sort of consistency so and
also so the items displayed don't change
based on what else you've got an action
bar so title subtitle list navigation
spinner and so it still has room for
those items and so if you help hide or
show eva any of those your items on your
item numbers in the change and i think
these are all documented on the design
guidelines if you go to the action web
page on the durban android Kong / design
/ pattern / action bar something like
that and then it's actually documented
that how many items always shown in each
size screen and orientation already
actually over the top any questions so
springy in the UK asks and he wants to
do bi-directional NFC and transceiving
like the google i/o example i see
ensberg Android Beam gets the way is any
way to work around bit I am sooo don't
know yeah I got Collins like solder I
don't know if that enough since or
hundred be able we've recently been
looking into this if at my boss was at
the bowlin Mobile World Congress
oh yeah beam does seem to be slightly a
bit of a problem with the extra touch
required it wasn't going down too well
with some people weren't familiar with
NFC I'm basically trying to find the
same kind of way around this issue for
doing a kind of message sort of
challenge response kind of two-way
process so at the moment I'm not getting
any answers out of that doesn't seem to
be any way around this at the moment
what was shown in the google i/o a few
years ago was a previous version before
they had to touch the beam and it's
slightly more easy to work around but I
think it's been tightened up since then
but yeah I'm in the same boat I'd love
to know if there's anything else coming
up or anything else has been announced
but van I think so far my suspicion is
no yeah I think so think Dean is the way
forward yeah it'd be great to for sort
of use cases that I'm facing and what
this other chaps facing is to have
something a mechanism for a sort of we
need sense of data and get a response
back and not sure what the best way is
for the moment so for this might be
great to find out their site like that
in the future right okay well guess
that's one we're gonna need em away go
we don't know thanks for the feedback
that's interesting to hear beam isn't
always the way forward okay wonderful
image your eyes on that one yeah so
there's the in-app billing okay one said
Jeremy from Australia is just
essentially having issues with in-app
billing since she was happening as his
activities being destroyed before he's
actually receiving the filling was dog
and then yeah crystal really kind of
melted on stackoverflow I said using a
lot of dialogue cabella Todaro fragment
and try posting runnable using run on UI
thread oh yeah so from our robot back
it's not really an issue with in
purchase and it's just a general sort of
Android issue where your league you're
showing a dialogue while the activity is
Michel and so it's just sort of fix me
leaked so it's sort of the in-app
billing side of it is kind of red
herring what for my red so yeah I mean
dialogue dialogue fragment was added so
you don't have to do this stuff anymore
so you don't have to handle the life
cycle and it's all handle for you
fragments and it's just the nice by
doing it so if you're going to obviously
there are some styling issues in it if
you can use that alertdialog it gives
you a lot of styling for free but i
think the pros of using dollar fragment
of the lifecycle sort of freeness is
good and i was a good place on the
android developers blog read about how
to use data fragment android dash
developers blogspot com you can find
that cool and the ball it's just another
stack overflow link and a look at this
one when to delete files shared with
external apps by content provider from
Martin in Slovakia page said river no
I'm not some will compatible yeah I'm
trafficking so Aaron is from the Canary
Islands is asked when are we going to
start taking the button via public so
bull tracker seriously and so there are
new 30,000 issues that nobody seems to
care about and some of them affect
millions of users and I mean as I've
said need replies of the tracker is
checked and is checked very regular than
everybody and it's just they may not be
replies on each of them and and sort of
fixes are putting it's going the way
that androids develop because Android
has developed internally at Google and
then open source and we've actually
maintained like a public so if private
bug tracker as well so and things like
that we'll look at and then we might
file internal bugs and work on those
internally and then he won't see them
you know thanks it a second a the bug
report you put in until the next release
when that codes pushed so it might seem
like we're not responding but we do
actually read them all and things like
you know adding Arabic support was
because it was another one star dish you
on track man like we do look at these
for prioritization as well so sorry if
it feels like you're whistling in the
wind but we do we do look at it so keep
funny so jump on staff room from in
France ask what's the best solution to
the awesome SSO solution with an
override of the authenticator class and
service the account is linked to an
external state which is their
credentials not quite sure is asking
manage the wrong I don't get that one
either so I'm guessing you're asking a
single sign-on situation so I guess
you're asking for like if you have this
device holder credential for your for
your service your site and have multiple
apps using it which case i'd say i use
account manager and infrastructure is
definitely the way forward to give that
and if that's not what your question is
can you please reply to the moderator
and clarifying shampoo why android is an
executing catch taking code the
exception is caught but is only
executing return statement or code
before it catches executed it's weird
this is the only normal i know case of
catching cim is working fine ah it
sounds very much like rufus if occur if
you mention our arm life um don't know
yeah I've get in touch to the delivery
where are likely that does not sound
like the general you know stay at the
world of catch statements are executed
else we've been a lot of
and so I Denis Londoners asked he's
using the google maps api version 2 and
the map fragment sometimes freezes but
it doesn't respond to user input and it
is super aware of misery fix and I don't
know check bed android com if there
might be a bug report already on there
um it might be a case you're doing
something on the UI thread as well you
know I'm thinking of moving up I guess
you could easily identify that if you
just had a button on the action bar or
something it's not good rather than the
whole UI spot or user access trace and
see what's going on ya know maybe you're
using a live sort of UI widget which
sort of intercepts touch events the
swing like a sliding library also think
tonight which is in setting such events
as seven points and so not fragment
Goodman yeah well as disgraceful table
to be on yeah you see where it is going
so Maris in Romania and asks is it
possible using Android assets studio
tool to preserve the content padding and
stretch reasons when creating an eye
patch right now when changing the image
the padding and stretch reasons already
set default I didn't I think that sounds
like a bug with them access to do if it
is doing that I don't mean that's
correct behavior so there is a GAO
report bug a bug tracker sections it's
just a google code project so if you can
file a bug on that then we'll take a
look there are any questions live all
are still going through these reckoning
each is at me you've always call
question oh I just wanted to ask you
another thing about the sliding menu the
same feature that we have right now on
google+ application and android i'm
looking for a library to do the same
effect to achieve the same effect and i
found several libraries and I want to do
you to guide me to a specific one that
you think it's more suitable slide it's
one is called sliding menu and it also
has a support for action
show up they finds day one there yeah I
think I try to load of them and sliding
menu seem to be the one that was the
most active with development they also
fix some stuff after Richard Hyndman had
kinda had a look and realized that you
were actually still painting the menu
even though it was invisible so they
ended up fixing that a lot of the others
didn't um it seemed like the most robust
one that i paid with Julia that's what
I'd go for but there are they right
handful okay thanks cool round so Andrew
one man mutters machine Kelly I'll asks
a long question if I background my app
using the home button there's any reason
why two seconds later and I realized yet
complete back stack is not restored I
have a front-row activity which keeps
getting shown when for grounding even
through it even though over and I think
you answer this one question yeah it's
once we need more information volume
more information um so I'd look for the
source of how it sort of your app is
actually relaunched from the recent apps
draw and there's takings that happen if
you're at least still sort of in memory
and still active it will just sort bring
it to the front and if not it will
launch in 10 based on various things
that will relaunch rap and so as your
I'm guessing that your app is still sort
of active so it's through the bring into
front and so I don't think about how how
this might happen and anything really
think is that you've got activities and
different tasks and so you've got your
activity stack and that's in a separate
task and then when you when it's brought
back to front it's Android is
relaunching your original task is that
your original activities being sort of
show again um but I said this is total
guests from the description you gave us
a flag sound like a bear the could
potentially you get mess up your history
there to check young react you have the
new task flag set on the activity which
you might be as desired behavior for
certain situations it's gonna do that
it's gonna be the behavior
ohs what would happen if you had then
keep activities tick to the developer
options that kill it if you hit the home
button hmm so that could be another
thing if you that's custom because I had
that before it was just killing some
stuff and I'd never really realized why
until I actually remembered i switched
on so that that might be something just
left on see I'm checking manifests and
also your intense and just triple-check
River you're doing some freaky stuff
cool and roam in chennai says is it
advisable to restart a service from
ondestroy and what happens to the data
storage or any search options when the
device power fails suddenly since shared
preferences use XML files easily use
fossil store data will the faulty be get
corrupted so the first question depends
on why you're actively being destroyed
of his duties service oh sorry sorry
chef so if it's been sort of destroyed
using memory constraints of the Android
is actively sub killing your service
what you should do to issue should you
start sticking because I'll
automatically doll this toy so I you
like it on Star Command and then return
the right value from on Star Command so
basically don't fight the system and
when it's trying to kill you trying to
restart yourself that sounds pretty
extreme and like really really trying to
avoid fighting the system so yeah more
look at you know starting sticky and
service and the system will restart you
when it has enough resources to run you
and if it is an important service you
can use stuff foreground and which will
mean your services as important as an
activity foreground pay attention and
you have to provide a notification and
second part the question was some debate
power loss yep and roof so there are
various things that can happen here and
mostly sort of depends on sort of a sort
of file systems whether sort of file
systems got a journaling so using the X
key free or whatever age but these are
all device specific sort of
implementation and so deadly surefire
you can do really is to try and combat
this if it ever happens so if you try
and read preference
and it's not there or it's been
corrupted or whatever or database has
been corrupted and to try and think of
ways to sort way around it so either no
key to create backups of database or
your preferences it is needed if you
really were but if he's like really
critical that you don't lose it then
probably you don't want to be using
these high-level abstractions like
shared preferences and databases you
probably want to be working at the file
level and then looking at the guarantees
at the different file systems will make
to you and you know bait you know if
you're super critical information like
financial information transaction
information you just cannot lose then
yeah you probably want to get a little
bit lower level and look at the games
they make and if it's not as critical
then you probably can rely on these high
level up straight abstraction so if
you're looking at shared preferences and
there's two ways you can either apply or
commit them the two different methods
one is going to be acing so there's
slightly larger chance of an you know
you're not knowing it's written and
before it returns control to you as if
you do the synchronous one you'll know
when it returns control to your program
that's been written so you can guarantee
it's being assisted so it depends on the
data and how critical it is how the
impact of losing any of it will be but
it generally not a massive issue I'd say
to worry about me i would say the other
night on it and right I think we've them
exhausted the moderator soluble
multiplus go yeah um if you have a
premium up with a lot of customers who
have already paid but you want to
transition to a premium app using in-app
purchases and subscriptions the google
play store or properly return the
original purchase status to the
licensing api want you to clear the app
to be free unfortunately not this is a
general problem of which we don't have a
great solution of migrating paid users
to a freemium model yeah and yeah I've
seen some innovative workarounds like &
laskins we saw the free view map and
then in the freemium app you use package
managers to Texas the premium one is
installed basically becomes like an
unlocker
and you can do it issue an update so
even removes the you know the Lord
Trigon but it stays installed as the
kind of like the unlocker app and then
enabling the same functionality as if
they done the app purchase so that's one
possible workaround the unfortunate year
and as we said that the service the LVL
won't won't return for free app so Luke
the chat was slippery missed this
question so how do you ask it now yeah
Luke what was your question q and mute
or you know Mike is also an ax money I
do not understand what you're off to us
at all sorry if you can reword it then
maybe we'll be able to it he has to be
quick but he's winning our time here so
thing is if you look from Australia I
think that's on and so he's happy that's
just wondering there's any way to change
the default composition I wrote on map
fragment and like a car frogs for
example and beast about to do this
senior ondraw method in version one was
in tonight you can envision to identity
answer them and I don't think you can
because most of the methods of final
nerve remember rightly they've really
tightened up not pregnant and all that
sort of related methods and said yeah
project is in the light you can any
other live questions or shoe wrap up a
little early three minutes oh except his
hand is up oh yeah just let's find it
easily few minutes okay um what is the
best approach for an application that
must upload to a socket to a socket
Cedric okay continuously stream I mean
suppose that I Cola the byte array from
the camera okay and I would like to
upload continuously to a dotnet server
okay what is the best approach for
android
work the socket system another another
way what did you suggest for
continuously upload and it turns me on
Commerce ready it's quite broad topic to
do this so it depends it does anything
real time so it does it need to be there
as fast as possible or is it kind of is
not loaded prior real time with this
family real time is some delay yeah 576
second date second is acceptable delay
so you essentially want to so the way
that I've done isn't it past was you can
essentially get access to the camera so
says you take the camera streams to get
on a surface view and then you can read
that there's a way to convert it to an
RTP stream and then essentially stream
that and read it from the server side
there's a couple of open source projects
that do this for you because there's one
little thing where the header of each
packet there is no sighs so yeah
basically RTP shoot the way it's done
this it needs to know the the packet
size and by default that won't get added
in so you have to do some typical round
of it but it makes a lot of sense in
terms of you're using a standard stream
protocol UDP so it's going to get there
as fast as they can yeah that's the way
I've done it I think you've a human tell
me about this before about the is at the
end data point something okay look Leo
source projects and you'll see what I
mean about like one of the length of the
packets not being right that's the only
caveat okay yeah
cool why so I think that brings us to
the end of our time today so thanks
everyone for joining us and as always we
do prefer if you can get their questions
in it ahead of time in the moderator so
it actually gives us a chance to to
research other stuff so again and get
you a better answer so yeah thanks
everyone for joining us and we'll catch
you same time next week bye guys bye
guys thank you